I wanted everyone to participate in us
having a tiny set tonight so I actually
had three tiny audience chairs made and
they're right here these are teeny-tiny
audience chair
[Music]
volunteers hello
how are you
I'm not picking you to sit there I just
want to talk no please why don't you
come on down what's your name Danielle
have a seat right there
touch her a natural hair color or to
finish I wish you dyed your hair to just
Rio okay let's get security down here
what's your name shows dead Dustin okay
here you go
good luck with this guy
Rainn Wilson from the office ladies and
gentleman where's your name sir Henry
your name's Henry come on down and join
us in the tiny seat right here I want
you to sit right there he could be
careful
that's Dustin and you are Danielle very
nice are those comfortable be honest
okay they clearly hate it you know in
honor of tonight's tiny set everyone who
works here is getting a tiny paycheck
isn't that nice regular check but it's
not very much I thought it was funny
they didn't know we only have an hour
then ladies and gentlemen to be honest
we have to get this furniture back -
Snooki's house so it's normal-sized you
know I cannot fight and so it's so weird
out I'm not used to seeing your whole
body stand there that's what I'm saying
I've never seen you stand before and you
can see my whole body it's very
distracting
yes it is believe it or not there is
real news in the world besides our a
miniature set did you hear this laser
diamond rush limbaugh has joined twitter
did you know that he joined twitter no
he won't be tweeting he just got hired
to replace the twitter fail whale which
i pause I was assured that was funny by
young people did you like it if you
liked it that's all I care about how
about you scary Conan clone bearded
killer how did you feel out it didn't
happen I think we had a small seat open
up down here right now
I'm with you hey disastrous news for
Walt Disney can you believe this Walt
Disney has announced that they've lost
200 million dollars on the movie John
Carter yeah this doesn't bode well for
Disney's upcoming 250 million dollar
epic Jimmy Carter that a movie no one's
gonna want to see where's his Hawaii
Carter on Mars that fantastic
yesterday Vice President Joe Biden said
that the killing of Osama bin Laden was
the most audacious plan in the last 500
years that's what he said
yeah Biden then unveiled his new line of
steak knives and said until now
[Applause]
anyone here get the new iPad yet the
hell it's the biggest tech sensation of
our lifetime no it has me stand in line
for things like this show yeah
in other words they're cheapskates is it
free well then I'm there well maybe you
guys haven't bought one a lot of people
have since Saturday Apple has sold three
million iPads three million yeah so to
the Chinese workers who made them juice
boxes all around celebrate kids
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]